for
[Music]
Christian
hello hello welcome everyone to the
table that goes for all of you folks
here in uh in the hall and those of you
online you are not only welcome here but
you are celebrated
here so a couple of announcements
today uh Five Loaves service day we will
be serving as a group at the local food
pantry that will be Saturday the 7th
from 900 a.m. to 12:30 p.m.
it is a familyfriendly opportunity we
will be passing out food and helping at
the warehouse so please scan the QR code
on the screen to sign up so we can let
them know how many of us are going to
show up
there also they are have a goal of
raising 50,000 pounds of food by
September the 19th so in order to help
we want to invite all of you to bring
your nonp perishable foods
that would be boxes cans Etc and bring
them next Saturday excuse me
Sunday next Sunday and drop them off
here in the lobby we're going to add our
collection to Saxy first uh it's already
begun uh begins so let us join together
and do something good for
others we have another great opportunity
something that happens every year it's
called the center peace conference this
is going to be October 24th through the
26th it'll be at the Wilshire Baptist
Church in Dallas uh Center peace is a
fully affirming Christ centered
organization that provides a place uh to
belong and nurtures the faith of lgbtq
plus folks and allies so again Phil if
you want more information want to
register use the QR coat uh on the
screen now I'd like to invite you to
just
take a deep
breath settle
in and we will exit the kingdom of noise
and hurry and
productivity now we will enter the
kingdom of silence and
Stillness and
simplicity Sacred
Space a place for prayer
prayer
worship and
adoration a place to behold
Christ the revelation of
God the heartbeat of
creation allow the unforced rhythm of
Grace to find
you to mend your
heart may we all come
home thank you Jenny you guys want to
stand with us we're going to get started
tonight with a highway women song High
women and Kaylin's going to lead us so
you guys can follow along with her um
but I love how this song embodies the
kind of community that we really want to
be making space for everybody here
[Music]
you can hold my
hand when you need to let
go I can be your
mountain when you're feeling valley
low I can be a stream
light showing you the way
home if you can hold my my
head when you need to let
go I want a house with a
crowded table and a place by the fire
forone let us Take On The World While
We're Young and able and bring us back
together
when the day is
done if we want a
garden we're going to have to S the
seeds PL a little
happiness Let The Roots Run
Deep if it's love that we give then it's
love that we reap if we want a garden
going to have to S the
seeds yeah I want a house with a
crow table and a place by the fire for
everyone let us Take On The World While
We're Young and a and bring us back
together when the day is done
the door is always open your pictures on
my
wall everyone's a little
broken yeah everyone
belongs yeah everyone
belongs I want a house with a
crowded table and a place by the fire
for every
one let us Take On The World While We're
Young and a and bring us back together
when the day is done and bring us back
together when the
day is
done
wo it's done
all right it's fun one kiddos you guys
are dismissed to your classes so you all
can go line up at the doors and your
teachers will take you back thank you
guys for being with us tonight hope you
have fun
thanks to our kids team who love these
kids week after week so grateful for
them and we are going to transition into
the prayers of the people so for those
of you who are new with us tonight this
is a tradition that goes back through
Christian history and it's a time for us
to lift up the things that we carry
through those doors into this space um
before God and before each other and
just hold that space um where can be
honest about the burdens that we're
carrying so we'll read this prayer
together um the parts that we read aloud
together are marked in red on the screen
so you can follow along with those and
um then in the middle of the prayer
we're going to just take a pause for you
to speak out loud a name or a situation
that's on your heart you can pray those
out loud and then we will continue
together and finish the
prayer Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
you are my
joy you are my
song You Are The
World the one I'm drawing from you are
my
refuge my whole life
long where else would I
go surely my God is the strength of My
Soul Your Love to f
Me Your Love defends me and when I think
like I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends
[Music]
me day after
day night after
night I will remember
you're with me in this fight all the the
battle he rages on the war
already
won I know the war's
W show me my Guidance the strength of My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me and when I feel like I'm all
alone you love defends Me You
Love We Sing
Hallelujah you're my portion my
[Music]
salvation surely my God is the strength
of my soul oh you love defends me you
love defends me and when I feel like I'm
all
alone you love defends me you love
defend me surely my God is the strength
of my
soul you love defends Me Your Love
defends me and when I feel like
I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me We
Sing
Hallelujah you're my portion my
salvation we sing
H you're my portion my salvation we sing
[Music]
hallelu you're my portion my salvation
we sing
halelujah
you're my
portion my salvation
God thank you that you're always with us
and you're always for us
[Music]
God my life is yours
and my hope is in you
only and my heart you
hold as you made this
inner
holy and
[Music]
holy
oh oh
holy your glory is so
[Music]
beautiful I fall onto my knees in
all and the hit of my life is to Worship
in your life your glory is so beautiful
[Music]
your glory is so
beautiful my life is yours my life is
yours and my hope is in in you
[Music]
ho my heart you hold my heart you
cuz you made this
s holy
[Music]
and your glory is so
beautiful I fall on to
[Music]
need the heartbeat of my life is to
Worship in your life your glory is so
beautiful Your Glory is so
beautiful w
[Music]
let's sing Glory Glory Glory
Glory
Hallelujah Jesus you are
good Glory
Glory Hallelujah
[Music]
Jesus you are
good Glory
Glory
Hallelujah Jesus you are good we sing
Hallelujah Jesus you are
[Music]
what can wash away my sins nothing but
the blood of
Jesus what can make me whole again
nothing but the blood of Jesus
oh precious is the
flow that makes me white as
snow
no I
know nothing but the blood of
[Music]
Jesus oh
of
[Music]
Jesus Glory
Glory
Hallelujah Jesus you are
good Glory
Glory Hallelujah
Jesus you are good sing that out to Him
Glory Glory
Glory
Hallelujah Jesus you are good oh he's
good Glory
Glory
Hallelujah Jesus you are
God glory glory
good Glory
Glory
Hallelujah you are good you are
good glory
glory
hallelu Jesus you are good yes
Glory
Hallelujah
Jesus you
[Music]
are it's God that's who we believe you
to be is a good
God one who calls us higher and
deeper into your ways
God root us into your
love would we be a tree planted by a
stream whose Roots grow deep into the
soil would we be people who can weather
the storms of
life because we are anchored into a deep
understanding that we are loved that we
are not alone that we will not be
forsaken that you will see us
[Music]
through thank you
God for who you are who you have been in
our
life who you will always
be
steadfast
holy just
righteous
kind
[Music]
forgiving God would we be marked by that
kind of fruit in our
[Music]
life continue to do your good work in
our
heart it's in your name we pray amen
[Music]
would you guys go ahead and welcome the
people sitting around you make them feel
seen and then Brett will get us started
on our message we're so glad you're here
morning
all
right try this one there we
go all right thank yall um so yeah so
Grace and peace so glad to be with you
um
and and to welcome you into the space
like I mentioned that includes those
join us online love you all lots and now
you can hear me now I'm not just going
like
this they can hear and uh anyone who is
new thanks for being here um you know it
can just be a lot coming through those
doors depending on your background and
you know the the his your history with
church and uh it can yeah it can be a
lot so we we recognize that and are
really glad that that you're here in
this space and kind of trusting enough
you know to like all right I'll give it
another go so um yeah so thank you for
for being here with us and um I also
want to mention before I jump into
things with our series and such um I
want to mention uh the conference that
johnine was mentioning
centerpiece uh so this is an
organization that is really they they're
there to kind of support lgbtq
Christians um and allies and so this
conference it happens every other year
and every time I've been there I've
thought like oh my gosh I wish like
everyone from the table could be at this
conference uh like I have the same
thought every time I realize it's like
not super feasible um but it's so it's
like Thursday night and then it's all
day Friday so you'd have take a day off
work and then some into Saturday uh but
it's just it's an amazing like I think
often churches like ours we can start to
feel a little bit isolated and alone
like we just kind of realize you know
we're like odd uh for the area you know
and so you just start to feel kind of
like I think we're just out here alone
you know and uh then you go to a
conference like that which is um it's
it's like so many people like of like
mind and so it's really it's a
conference that's not just for lgbtq
Christians but it's really like if
you've ever wondered like I don't know
just had thoughts or questions around
like scriptures and sexual orientation
and gender and like and just all of
Christian Theology and like how is all
that working and you know even at a
church like this it's you know it's not
like I'm preaching on all that stuff
like every week or something so you know
it's just a great resource like to feel
like you're not alone to ask interesting
questions to you they have um breakout
sessions I me it just it's fabulous so
okay so that's my plug it's in a few
months um go to that conference if you
can is it's freaking awesome okay plug
over so we are in a series right now uh
titled The Parables of Jesus and uh
parables are these of course these kind
of short stories that Jesus used as like
teaching um opportunities and uh some
what some perceive as kind of their um
their weakness oh yeah if you want the
QR code for the for the conference
that's that's what you need um so what
some perceive is kind of their weakness
which would maybe be like you know they
can be kind of
open-ended uh in fact some Scholars
think that anytime you have a parable
and then an interpretation where Jesus
kind of gives the interpretation like to
the disciples or something certain
Scholars actually think that might be
the gospel writer kind of adding that in
and that Jesus himself never actually
like gave the interpretation which is
kind of an interesting you know thoughts
I don't know we don't know for sure if
that's true but it does seem like Jesus
really liked to teach in these Parables
where in essence they can be kind of
open-ended and you might feel like well
that's kind of their weakness like I I
need to know the truth so like just you
know tell it straight like like don't
don't confuse us but I actually think
that the kind of
open-endedness is an invitation right
that The Parables they speak to you for
like years because you just keep kind of
opening up new meanings and new levels
so that's kind of what we're doing in
this series is um starting to look at
some of these and you know reflect more
deeply on them so with that in mind the
title of my message this week is the
parable of Lazarus and the rich man and
I don't think I've ever preached on this
one so I'm I'm excited for it so our
passage is Luke chapter 16 uh verses 19
through
31 and so the story goes like this there
was a rich man who was dressed in purple
and fine linen and lived in luxury every
day at his gate was laid a beggar named
Lazarus covered with Soares longing to
eat what fell from the rich man's table
even the dogs came and licked his sores
the time came when the beggar died and
the angels carried him to Abraham's side
the rich man also died and was buried
and Hades where he was in torment he
looked up and saw Abraham far away with
Lazarus by his side so he called to Him
Father Abraham have mercy on me and send
Lazarus to dip the tip of his finger in
water and cool my tongue because I'm in
agony in this fire but Abraham replied
son remember that in your lifetime you
received your good things while Lazarus
received bad things but now he is
comforted here in and you are in agony
and besides all this between us and you
a great Chasm has been set in place that
those who want to go from here to you
cannot nor can anyone cross over from
there to us he answered well then I beg
you father send Lazarus to my family for
I have five brothers let him warn them
so they they will not also come to this
place of Torment Abraham replied they
have Moses and the
prophets let them listen to
them no Father Abraham he said but if
someone from the dead goes to them they
will
repent he said to them or to him if they
do not listen to Moses and the prophets
they will not be convinced even if
someone rises from the dead maybe a
little a little nod there to the
resurrection of Christ to
come so okay so let's start uh by kind
of unpacking and naming what I don't
think this Parable is about uh I I think
I I don't think its primary purpose is
to give us some sort of
literal insight into heaven and hell I
think that's probably a first reading
would be like oh that's clearly this is
a parable about heaven and hell you know
like Lazarus obviously he went to the
good place and the rich man he went to
the bad place and there's the chasm
right so he sees them up like in the
heavens and they're like sort of weirdly
though they're able to talk and uh
they're communicating across I guess
that's how it'll be in the life to come
we'll we'll change chat you know across
and uh I don't think so so um for one
thing this
actually so the term here being used is
not I think we hear the term Hades we're
like aha hell uh but actually no so the
the the kind of Hebrew like Old
Testament equivalent for Hades Hades is
Greek would be shol um which simply
means the place of the dead so Hades
literally means the place of the dead so
this this Parable is it's a little bit
more kind of Old Testament theology I
mean if you asked for like what's the
Biblical teaching on the
afterlife uh that gets tricky because
there's kind of a develop there's like a
theological development of the idea so
the Old Testament idea was basically you
know where did you go when you died to
the place of the
Dead Hebrew Hades Greek so so that's why
like in this Parable they're able to
kind of speak to one another precisely
because they're not in different places
does that make sense so it's not heaven
hell the chasm like um in fact I I won't
go too far into this there's like lots
of nerdy research and stuff there's
great so like some Scholars think he's
that uh Luke here is pulling from or or
perhaps Jesus uh is is kind of pulling
from a book called The Book of Enoch
which in chapter 22 describes Hades is
the place the dead as this kind of place
of like kind of mountains and valleys
some kind of lush and beautiful and
delightful others kind of harsher and
hot and and such which is it's like it's
a little different than kind of the
classic image of hell for example and
there's the demons like no it's not that
it's just sort of the the place of the
righteous going to the cooler more you
know Pleasant valleys and then the place
of the kind of the unrighteous is the
it's like sort of yeah uncomfortable and
not kind I mean honestly it Maps like
perfectly
onto this Parable so um and the Book of
Enoch was like huge hit in the first
century I know now probably no one's
read it but back then it was like New
York Times bestseller all the early
Christians and and uh Jews at that time
love The Book of Enoch so so it's very
possible something like that which again
doesn't map super well onto Heaven hell
like we have all these developed
theologies we're like running with this
um no it's it's it's something different
here this is I think what Jesus Jesus is
doing in other words is kind of using
imagery using this idea of like Hades
the place of the Dead to kind of make a
well in essence to make a different
point entirely in other words not to
give us detailed info about the
afterlife where apparently we can talk
and stuff across the CM like no it's
there's something else uh Jesus is
getting at and um it's that something
else that I I want to focus on tonight
so um let's back up a bit and uh let's
let's kind of go through this Parable
let's let's talk about um the this rich
man who notably is not
named which is interesting if you think
about it like in the world today is that
normal that the poor and the
destitute that we know their
name and that the rich are like nameless
faceless not so much right like of
course we all know you know the the
names of you know Bill G
or you know Elon Musk or what like we
these are the names that like oh yeah we
know we know CU because they have names
and faces and popularity and power and
such but the poor know it's but so it's
interesting I think that's already a
hint a little bit as to what's going on
in this Parable that you have
Lazarus named and then generic the rich
man you know it's this kind of nameless
faceless uh kind of person
uh then you you've got verse 19 also
says this there was a rich man who was
dressed in purple in fine linen and he
lived in luxury every day uh the word
for luxury there in Greek is lampros
which means like opulence or Splendor so
this it's not like and he had a little
money like no no no this in fact we know
actually from the next verse that he
had a gated
driveway which even even today that's
like a little fancy you know but in the
first century gated driveway like this
is
like this guy you know so we're talking
opulence Splendor incredi he's just
incredibly powerfully wealthy uh now his
plight of course is completely
contrasted with that of Lazarus right
the uh well verse 20 and 21 puts it this
way at his gate was laid a beggar named
Lazarus covered with sores and longing
to eat what fell from the rich man's
table people even the dogs came and
licked his
sores obviously his State like right
could not be more different uh not not
only I mean he's not just poor right
he's he's a beggar uh and apparently has
some sort of kind of physical Affliction
so it's not just a lack of money but
it's like physically emotionally
financially I mean just in every way the
the picture here really is one of utter
destitution and the implication it's
it's not it's not explicitly named in
the parable the
implication based on where they end up
in the place of the dead right would
seem to be that this rich man uh did not
do a lot for Lazarus Who Sat by his gate
I mean presumably if he had been oh so
merciful and right well he wouldn't have
ended up in in the place of the
unrighteous you know what I mean so so
that's kind of the implication of the
story seems to be that Lazarus sat there
day after day after a year after maybe
decade and this Rich Gentleman Just did
absolutely nothing for him so okay so as
we read earlier they both die they go to
the place of the Dead the rich man then
looks across this kind of valley right
Book of Enoch he's kind of sees across
the valley and sees Lazarus with the
patriarch Abraham by his side and then
that brings us to verse 24 which I think
is one of the pivotal lines in the
Parable God I love this so so he called
to Him Father
Abraham have what Have
Mercy have mercy on
me have
mercy that's an interesting word isn't
it like
oh you you would like
Mercy
you you want
Mercy you of all people oh now what's
happening you're in the place where
suddenly what you're in
need it's can you see this roll reversal
like
suddenly he's in need of Mercy like
Lazarus Sat by his gate every day of his
miserable life in need of what
what
mercy and the implication again it's not
explicitly named the implication seems
to
be it was not
forthcoming just did not
happen and uh in fact that there is a
character in the story maybe characters
plural who do or did I should say show
Lazarus Mercy remember which character
not it's not human
characters it's the
dogs remember it said um that they would
uh they were licking their lips you know
or not lick I should say they weren't
licking their like this is not the image
I don't think of them like haha they
would lick his wounds like as though
they want to just licking their chops
ready to like you know get him like no
no no I think the picture of the dogs
here is um actually that they
instinctively showed
Mercy that it's like what naturally
you've ever you know had a wound it's
sort of it is a little bit creepy when a
dog comes up to you and starts like
licking your you know it's like okay
this is good um but it's just
instinctive you know what I mean there's
just a sense of caring of tending of
cleaning of helping in other words the
dogs the Dogs showed more Mercy to
Lazarus than the this rich man the
dogs but now of course it's
oh I need I'm in need mercy and notice
too it's
not
Lazarus I am so sorry like I was blind
but now I see now I see it oh my God how
could I have been so like I think that
would be like completely different story
could find start finding some compassion
for it no no no no no no no it's not
that is it it's not I've been so blind
I've been so stupid please forgive me
and if you could have mercy on me the
mercy I didn't give you like no no no no
instead he speaks to the person of
authority Abraham and says Abraham have
have him take care of me like have send
him tell him Abraham tell him what to do
you can see I'm in need so
suddenly he's in need and now he's he's
ordering him around there's a wonderful
paraphrase of the New Testament uh
that's like it's decades old now it's
called The Cotton Patch gospel by
Clarence Jordan where he basically he
put a lot of the New Testament into a
kind of Southern dialect and humor and
such and uh yeah here it is uh and of
course keep in mind the kind of History
right of and racism and such of the
United States so you can see oh Father
Abraham send me my water boy water boy
quick I'm just about to perish down here
I need a drink of
water that's how he paraphrases this
passage I think that's a brilliant right
he's drawing
out what's there in the story right here
he is in in the place of the dead here
he is in Hades and he still does not get
it like he still refusing to use
lazarus's name right and here it's water
boy in this paraphrase or in the story
it's speaking to Lazarus through Abraham
right but not addressing him directly
and it's still he's still ordering him
around get give me I need some water uh
go to tell them to go to my family tell
them to make sure that they right and
he's just ordering him
around he still doesn't get it and and
the kind of the worst part is is
throughout the story he never does like
that's that's just kind of How The Story
Goes he he he doesn't see
it the whole time right he's totally
blind to his treatment of
Lazarus in uh in our table Meetup I meet
with um some guys on Saturday mornings
and we always have a book we're going
through and so we've been going through
Dr David gush's after evangelicalism
uh which is a fantastic book and uh he
has this quote that just completely I
just thought got right to the heart of
of things so much of a Christian culture
right now and uh I think as it pertains
to this passage so Dr David gushy he
wrote these words he said Christian
identity has often been hopelessly
confused and merged with national
identity to be born in 1820s England was
to be Anglican Christian wasn't much
different from being born in 19 50s
Jackson Tennessee where the I like this
unofficial official religion was
Southern Protestant Christianity in many
places was or is the Civil religion of
the nation and people have often not
really known the difference between
being a Christian and being a Brit or
American or German or Serb this is
routinely disastrous for Christian
witness because Christians who are
confused this is the key line who are
confused about their Court identity
often abandon the teachings of Jesus for
the demands of other
Lords notably the nation itself without
knowing what they are doing such
identity confusion is a major problem
for white Christians whose identity is
mingled with americanism whiteness
capitalism
republicanism you see I think the
disturbing part of this
story is
is the rich man is he a good man no I
don't think he is but is he like
particularly pernicious malevolent evil
like did he do the story say that every
time he rode on his horse by his gate
and saw Lazarus there he mocked him and
he said oh you're so weak and ridiculous
and you're like no no no no no you know
what he
did he
just ignored him
probably maybe just didn't even notice
him like in other words the rich man
he's he's just a man of his
time you know like not particularly bad
or Wicked or like no no he's just you
know he's just like a man of the time
it's like
normal right with but the the problem
there is but with all of the
prejudices all of the blind
spots all of the cultural
conditioning of his
time in essence um he's just like going
with the flow you know and in the
process becoming the
worst you're right just where you read
the story water boy this and that you
know I mean it's just like oh it's just
cringy it's just oh god oh no how do we
how do we end up here oh
easy
easy you
just you just end up
there right these blind spots he just he
he was a man of his time with the blind
spots of his time what are these blind
blind spots of class of course I think
factor in the story clearly uh blind
spots of potentially e eity and racism
blind spots of Education blind spots
just of cultural conditioning right and
so he just he does he goes with the
float and he ends up painfully
unself-aware
self-absorbed and as I said even by the
end of the story he like he just he
can't see it he doesn't get it right he
he doesn't know what he's doing uh but
he's doing it he doesn't know what he's
doing but he's doing
it and uh of course I guess it's in
these settings there's always the
question of who do we identify with you
know in the story uh and I do think
there's a place to identify with Lazarus
you know to feel uh at times when we are
the Disposable one or at least made to
feel that way we are the marginalized
one we're you know and we have those
moments um sometimes not even moments
those seasons and feels like a times you
know lifetimes um but I also tonight I
want to kind of shift it around though
cuz I think it would be easy to I don't
know kind of Pat ourselves in the back
like yeah can you believe those horrible
rich people and you know I'm certainly
not one of them and kind of move on uh
and feel real good about ourselves I I
think the disturbing question is like
how much am I like this
guy that's
the that's the question that that's the
thing in front of
us like to what degree am I just a
product of my
time with all the prejudices and blind
spots of my time when I was uh in middle
school I had a a Christian
t-shirt that said go against the flow I
did a search for it you can go ahead and
put it up I searched for it in the last
two weeks and I found it although it was
listed under vintage Christian t-shirts
from
1989 that's what it said and I was like
oh vintage what this is yesterday
V vintage so apparently I'm vintage now
um so I had this Shir I had the white
shirt version um and it's but it was all
the same go against the flow and then
you can see here you've got like the
evil fish you know that shark look at
that shark and that bottom feeder with
those giant teeth and the light thing
right so there I think there's a piranha
up there so you can see there's kind of
like the bad fish right and that's the
the people of the time right they're
going the non-Christian right they're
going that way and then You' got the one
little good fish the little you can see
the Christian fish kind of slipped in
there and uh I do think I mean honestly
I think this is a good message you know
yes go against the flow in essence it is
the me that's the message I'm preaching
you know go against the flow uh be
countercultural yes uh the trick of this
shirt um is it makes it look very
obvious and
easy that's the trick right in essence
it makes it like this is how I Vision at
like 8th grade Brett was like when
people offer you drugs you got to go
against the flow and say no you know I
saw some Instagram real or something
where people were talking about like as
a Evangelical Christian I definitely
grew up thinking people are going to
offer me drugs more often than actually
happened you know just like this is
going to happen every day you know um
and this is like this is kind of how you
envision it you know or at least how I
Envision like it's it's going to be
obvious you know so in those moments you
just that and that's when we're doing it
guys we're counter cultur we're going to
be different and you know and so on and
so forth
uh
no no I mean maybe at times but mostly
no no the trick is what do you do when
you're like surrounded by like other
Christian fish they're like all going
this way and then you're like ah but
that like really doesn't seem to be the
way of Jesus that doesn't seem to be the
heart of
Christ but everyone say says that's the
way that's the path that's the truth oh
oh gosh you know and then your familyes
like this is the way you know and they
all the little fish are going the like
suddenly suddenly to actually go against
the flow and be a countercultural
follower of Christ is
astoundingly difficult and and never and
I say never happens by
accident
never the way I might summarize it is to
say um fish don't accidentally swim
upstream and people don't accidentally
become countercultural followers of
Christ you know like I just looked into
it it was so great like it just ended up
like I was just kind of going these fish
and we just it was perfect like no
it's tough it's tough to go against the
flow because there is there's a power in
we you know there's a power in the tribe
there's a power in the in the even the
masses and the mass movements there's
there's power there you just it just
kind of sweeps us up it's very hard to
say like I
disagree and step out sometimes alone
it's
incredibly
difficult yeah it's hard to go against
the kind of prejudices and blind spots
of your class your ethnicity your
political party your church your
religion your age your sexual
orientation gender country right these
these tribes are very powerful and they
say this is what we think on topic
XYZ and oh
it's so difficult to discern like okay
what's the what's the path
forward so I've been thinking like um
how do we actually do that I think the
the word that comes to mind is
intentionality there there must be an
intentionality in our
discipleship uh how does that look you
know I think honestly it looks it looks
like doing weird things
right because if everyone were doing it
well then it wouldn't be countercultural
you know what I mean like this in
essence like I think this is what Jesus
says when he says um the way is narrow
if you find
it that I think this is why uh because
it's just not comfortable I'm thinking
of um in meetups this week you'll be
able to kind of discuss this more um but
thinking of like there's something about
we kind of have to we have these little
bubbles I think we kind of live in you
know these cultural bubbles these little
perspectives and to bust out of them um
you you have to kind of intentionally
like meet different people like people
who maybe even make you a little
uncomfortable that's like the more
uncomfortable the
better you know like to get you out of
these class ethnicity political party
Church religion age sexual orientation
gender country right this is how we got
to kind of start breaking out of that so
it becomes relational
becomes people um it becomes kind of
study reading right again not getting
kind of locked in to like I don't know
another Max Leo book or you know
whatever I'm sure maxo is great um but
we kind of locked in on these little
like this is what I do this is who I
read this is my little world you know
and we've got to kind of break that open
one way we do that at the table is we
have a value we call it um our value for
being
eclectic and this is where this plays in
where it's so good to get outside your
little bubble of ideas and people um to
become countercultural in that way um I
think it also happens just kind of in
spiritual practice where um there is
something to be said for community and
relationship that's important some
people who can kind of call you on your
stuff but also there is something about
getting alone as we often talk here at
the table about there there is something
about leaving the crowds behind so that
you can discern the true voice the voice
of God within saying this is the way
walk in it this is what I'm calling you
to I don't
care what your Fillin the blank thinks
about
it and there there comes these times and
these places where we have to step out
and so what I'm kind of encouraging us
here at the table is may this be kind of
our season to be intentional to go
deeper to go deeper that way at the end
of all things we don't end up like this
rich man just a product of our time of
our ERA with all the prejudices and
blind spots of our time and our era but
instead that we become people of
profound wisdom and moral courage a
courage forged in the fires of
solitude in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we take in the body of Christ
tonight as we take in the blood of
Christ in the in the wine may this be a
moment where you
discern the true voice the voice of the
spirit God speaking to
you the things God's calling you into uh
maybe things where you need to kind of
repent too ways where we've gone with
the flow in ways it's like oh that was
not who Christ is calling me to be um so
whatever you need this time to be I I
encourage you to kind of come with a
with an open heart and mind into it uh
so the way we'll go about participating
in communion tonight is we'll start with
the front rows here and uh we'll just
kind of work our way back we'll form one
line right here uh we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you'd like to
participate then uh you are free to do
that regardless of your exact like
theology or denominational affiliation
or whatever um you're you're welcome to
participate you should know the red is
wine the white is grape juice and then
finally you are free to um just partake
whenever you'd like some folks like to
take right away others like to come and
kneel here at the front and take some
time there others like to return to
their seats and partake there but no one
will lead you through the exact like
moment of partaking so this is the table
not at the church but of the Lord and
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so
come you who have much faith and you who
have
little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long you
who have tried to
follow and you who
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
Brett um had told me what he was is
going to be sharing this Sunday um and
so I had picked out this song called
called me higher and um as I Was
preparing for today throughout the week
and thinking about the lyrics and
realizing that um this message he was
talking about about having to
intentionally make the decision to move
in a countercultural direction how this
community for me has been one of those
areas where I intentionally chose to to
start this community which was very
countercultural to uh the way I was
raised to what my family would feel best
about to what my the leadership that I
had been a part of that had invested in
me that raised me up I mean this was
very uh this was not safe this was not
comfortable um like making that move
making that shift but the fruit that
that's come from it and the ways that
I've experienced God change me from the
inside out and and show me Prejudice
that I had that I didn't even realize
was there and now asking myself today
not just patting myself on the back and
being like good you did the thing you
you know but realizing like what is it
today that I'm unaware of what is what
is the next thing that God's saying
there's more here go deeper go higher
like there's a higher calling Mindy you
know don't let yourself off so easy you
know don't just check the box but
continually staying in that posture of
like what is he calling us
to where's the shift where's the next
shift that's going to be
uncomfortable unsafe maybe you know
disregarded by
others and opening oursel up to that so
if you guys would like to stand with me
tonight if you if you feel that same
kind of impression on your heart if you
want to just open your hands as you sing
this song Sometimes a physical action is
just a great way to um kind of embody
what God might be speaking to us and
maybe just ask him as we sing together
what are you calling us to God where
where is it that you're wanting us to
step out or be different or change and
let's just kind of open up to him in
this
[Music]
area I could just
set I could just sit and wait for all
your goodness hope to feel your
presence I could just
stay I could just stay right where I am
and hope to feel you hope to feel
something again
[Music]
I could hold
on I could hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the
inside I could be
save I could be safe here in your arms
and never leave home never let these
walls down but you have called me higher
you have called me deeper and I'll go
where you
me
Lord you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord where you'll Lead
[Music]
Me
me sing I could hold
on I could hold
on I could hold on on to who I am and
never let you change me from the
inside I could be
save I could be save here in your arms
and never leave home never let these
walls down but you have called me higher
you have called me deeper and I'll go
where you will me
[Music]
Lord you have called me high
you have called me deeper and I'll go
where you will me Lord sing that one
more
time you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me
[Music]
Lord you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord You Lead Me
you're Le
me I will be
yours and I will be yours oh I will be
yours for all my
life that out I will be
yours I will be yours for all my life
yeah I will be yours oh I will be yours
for all my life so let your
mercy
you I will be yours oh I will be yours
for all my life so let your mercy light
the path before me CU you have called me
higher you have called me deeper and
I'll go where you will leave
me
Lord you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will leave me Lord
oh you have called me higher you have
call me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord
oh you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord you'll lead
[Music]
me you're Lead Me
Lord You're
Lead Me
[Music]
what about that
worship just wanted to say to everyone
thank you so much for being here but
especially to our visitors we'd really
like to get to know you better and so
there is a visitor's card over on the
little table over there as you go out
the way or you can scan the QR code and
fill out an online card uh that will
allow us to follow up with you we can
answer any questions that you might have
and say thank you for being here with
us so my name is johnine and if you're
in need of a hug or a prayer or just any
kind of General support find me after
the service I'll be happy to spend some
time with
you um generosity is a key aspect of the
life of adoration and worship so if
you'd like to help us and give
financially you can scan the QR code or
you can visit theable tx.org
and
now let me send you into your week with
this
blessing you can stand if you're
comfortable doing so and hold out your
hands in a posture to receive or you can
just open your hearts to these
[Music]
words you are a a child of
God
you you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with all of its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved that you are worthy
that you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come in contact
with be
blessed and we will see you next
Sunday there will be your
I will be yours for my
life oh I will be yours oh I will be
yours for all my
[Music]
life I will be
yours I will be yours all my life so let
your
mercy
o I will be
yours I will be yours through all my
life so let your mercy light the path
before me cuz you have called me higher
you have called me deeper and I'll go
where you will lead me
Lord you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will leave me Lord oh you have called me
higher you have called me deeper and
I'll go where you will lead me Lord
oh you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord You Lead Me
[Music]